you know I walked into this my life was
on fire uh shame like I had never
experienced before kind of Shame you
forget how to breathe so I read the
gospel with this man Jude I keep hearing
let go and to a person who's been
gripping so tight for so long it feels
like the right move to let go like
complete surrender for real and it stops
being this like prep of a movie I know
now like my God was using my ego to draw
me to him was drawing me away from
worldly desires it was all happening
simultaneously a lot of celebrities are
converting but is it all for show or is
it for real find out on this episode of
LED live
foreign
[Music]
exposing Darkness hey everybody Welcome
to LED live we've got a another show for
you and we've got an awesome special
guest Mr Samuel Tucker welcome to the
show Samuel Hello nice to see everybody
well I'm excited to hear
what you are gonna present today because
uh this is kind of something that I
think hits home with every Christian
we're starting to see people giving
their hearts what it appears that
they're giving their hearts to God
that's what we're laboring for but is it
real is it not so I really am curious
but tell us a little bit about yourself
Samuel what what is it is it that you do
no yes so well my wife and I uh we have
a Ministry called Glad Tidings 3 A.M
um just as a quick little interject that
we actually have a YouTube ministry as
well uh called Glad Tidings uh 3am that
you can look up on YouTube and so uh we
do YouTube ministry as well we have a
different on different social media
Outlets uh we travel and speak and
things uh things of that nature that's
actually where our brother Scott and I
met at a local uh Christian convention
uh out in Oregon and so that was a real
blessing and so uh that's uh what my
wife and I uh do
awesome all right so uh let's dive into
this what do you got for us today
yeah so uh it's it's a very good point
you know especially when it comes to you
know this whole subject of conversion
because at the end of the day we're
Christians you know so our desire as
Christians is to see other persons
converted
um but especially when it comes to
conversion you know this true conversion
and there's also false conversion and
it's really important to understand that
uh not just for those of us who are
believers but especially as we're
seeking to minister to people in the
world uh it's really important to
understand that distinction and
especially when it comes to a lot of the
uh conversions you know quote unquote
you know that we see in in the the
celebrity world and things like that
and again you know even the purpose of
this is not to unnecessarily label
people in a bad light or to say that
what their you know elements of what
they're experiencing is not genuine uh
but as Christians you know we really
want to be very watchful and Vigilant uh
when it comes to when it comes to
different things and so
uh when as it pertains to this
particular subject I was on the internet
and you know just as you know with
everything you know like you know you're
on the computer and you know you see
pumped up you know in your news feed you
know different uh subjects and articles
that come up and so the article that I
saw was in regards to Shia LaBeouf uh
being converted now we're all familiar
with you know Shia LaBeouf I remember I
used to watch him on a television
program called Even Stevens I don't know
if anybody here is familiar with that uh
television program but um that was a
part of my childhood you know and so I
kind of followed his uh career you know
as it were you know he was a part of the
Transformers
uh franchise you know um he got a lot of
notoriety you know as a result of that
and so you know certainly from a worldly
standpoint he was very successful
uh but I don't know how many of us are
familiar but unfortunately he he's had a
lot of
uh personal setbacks
uh in his life and as a result of that
it's really led him to be even as it
were kind of blacklisted even in
um Hollywood you know because of some of
his bad behavior
but recently the article going back to
the article that I saw it was talking
about how Shia LaBeouf had converted uh
to Roman Catholicism as a result of him
playing in a particular uh upcoming film
uh that is going to be on depicting uh
the role of a Catholic priest and so it
really piqued my interest and so as a
result of that I started to do some
digging and as I started to look into it
more there were a lot of very
interesting things uh that I found out
so can I ask a question what was he
converting from yeah so that's a very
good question so um he was mentioning in
an interview that I was watching with
him uh there is a pretty prominent uh
Catholic bishop in America called the
father I believe his name is Robert
Barron and he had a sit-down
conversation with um uh the bishop Baron
and he was mentioning that he was of the
Christopher Hitchens Samuel Harris
persuasion I don't know if any of our
listeners may be familiar with any of
those men but as Samuel Harris and
Christopher Hitchens unfortunately
Christopher Hastings has passed away but
those two men were very prominent uh
atheist intellectuals
um and there were a lot of arguments
that they uh would bring forth in order
to combat religion and Christianity and
things like that and because they were
so intellectual you know a lot of people
in society have tended to espouse uh
their belief system and so Shia LaBeouf
was kind of coming out of that type of
vein and and again you know being an
actor you know very you know artsy in
his in his thinking and and things like
that so uh that was really the
background that he was coming out of and
I don't know if you all have seen this
as well
um but especially in a lot of movies you
know Catholic imagery is very prominent
um I don't know if you remember
um there was a movie that came out I
think it was either early earlier this
year or late last year but it was um the
second uh Venom movie I don't know if
you all uh saw any ads for that
so um some of the fight scenes
especially the end fight scene that took
place in that uh movie uh took place
specifically in a Catholic Church
And in regards to a lot of the
investigation that I've done in regards
to these things generally speaking the
only
uh Christian churches as a word that are
used generally in movies is
predominantly Catholicism
for them for the most part it's
generally Catholicism that's used in
movies
and even you know just some film history
um you know even Alfred Hitchcock you
know Alfred Hitchcock is considered you
know still by I believe IMDb
as the most influential and uh the
greatest you know director of all time
and you know according to his you know
autobiography you know Alfred Hitchcock
uh was raised a Roman Catholic and so in
a lot of Alfred Hitchcock's movies
there's a lot of uh Catholic morale and
imagery that are uh interspersed
throughout his um movie catalog so um
for our viewers here we uh currently
have on our screen so uh just a little
interject so uh this is actually a
picture of Shia LaBeouf in the upcoming
movie that he's uh playing and so the
particular character that he's playing
it's actually I believe it was an
Italian priest named uh Padre Pio and uh
Padre Pio is not you know just an
ordinary uh Catholic priest but uh Padre
Pio is actually a saint as well so for
uh those of our listeners who do not uh
know about uh that whole process is that
um when a Catholic a person whether they
may be a laity or a part of the clergy
if they manifest on Miracles
um according to uh their understanding
and things like that then a person is
essentially
uh it gives them the opportunity to
become a saint in the Catholic church
and so uh Padre Pio he's a saint
and as a result of that they wanted to
do something to depict his life and so
uh Shia LaBeouf uh was the actor that
was a pick for this now there's a very
interesting article that I saw from the
Rolling Stone and now notice this
this says Shia LaBeouf says he converted
to Catholicism after portraying Mystic
friar in upcoming film now it was very
interesting
I'm not going to read all the details of
every article but just try I'm just
going to try to get out the uh the main
points so it says Shia LaBeouf was so
inspired by the subject of his latest
film project that it spurred the actor
to convert to Catholicism
it says the Scandal written 36 year old
who raised who was raised Jewish is set
to portray Catholic saint Padre Pio a
20th century
Franciscan Capuchin Friar and Mystic
now for those uh of our listeners that
don't uh understand what a Mystic is
this has to do with mysticism
now this has to do with spiritualism and
all of these things uh that the Bible
talks about that we should uh stand
clear from
but um as you'll find a uh many of the
times the the cases that a lot of uh
Catholic uh priests and and persons
associated with that class
a lot of them have been Mystics a lot of
them have been Mystics
and so it goes on to say he says alleged
to have the ability to communicate with
angels and could heal the sick it says
that LaBeouf spoke to his of his
Newfound spiritual beliefs in an
interview with Bishop Robert Barron so
that's who we were talking about before
Bishop Robert Barron
it says who himself has drawn scrutiny
from both conservative and liberal
Catholics for his controversial opinions
and it talks about the different
scandals that unfortunately uh the
bishop was a part of now going on in the
article it says noting that his actions
which span accusations of sexual assault
and abuse against at least three women
to arrest for battery and disorderly
conduct led to Serious infliction of
pain and damage on other people so this
is what uh Shaya is talking about his
experience
it says LaBeouf stated he was thrown
into a deep depression in recent years
and you know even as we come on and we
talk about these different things this
is by no means to make light of or to or
to to denigrate
um the genuineness of what Shaya is is
going through
because as we know just with The Human
Experience in general that God uses uh
trial and conflict in order to draw us
closer to him so that you know so this
is by no means to to negate those things
that shine is going through
um and so it goes on to say thrown into
a deep depression in recent years
particularly after his ex-girlfriend FKA
twigs found a lawsuit against him for
Relentless abuse and you know sometimes
I really think about this especially you
know because you know they're you know
for a little like Studios
you know making a lot of uh you know
content in regards to you know
celebrities and this is Daniel and I
know that this is uh something that you
won't think about as a lot as well is
especially as Christians you know when
we think about sharing the gospel you
know we certainly think of reaching you
know uh people who are in poverty you
know we think about you know reaching
people who you know live in the suburbs
or even going to a foreign country you
know to um you know Reach people in very
destitute situations and we should do
that
but many times I think about like what
type of serious active work is being
done to reach people in in the very high
echelons of society like what type of
systematic work is being done by us as
Christians to reach people like Shia
LaBeouf you know to reach people that
are you know say athletes or or
presidents or whatever the case may be
because a lot of times with these people
they live in such a a bubble
and I know that some of us you know can
attest this I know that uh you know you
brother Scott can you know really you
know identify with this is that you know
when you're in those circles it's not as
easy to come in contact with the gospel
of Christ and unless you know there are
people to really go out of their way to
cease to reach those classes a lot of
times you know these dear beloved people
you know can you know even go to crisis
Graves you know so that's the thought
that I I think about a lot I remember
when um the actor from Two and a Half
Men
kind of was you know coming out and and
being converted I actually had a
conversation with him and he said the
exact same thing he said you know I
really feel like God woke me up and and
I started having Bible studies and he
really felt like his heart being tugged
to go out and reach the celebrities now
if if if he's done that I don't know I I
only had one conversation with him so
it's hard to say what what he actually
like has gone on and transpired and done
but um yeah I mean he said that it is
very difficult because a lot of times
those circles are surrounded around
people who really don't care about
religion and you know it's it's not easy
to penetrate through some of those
circles and get to them I think that's a
fair point it's a point that can be made
from our Vantage Point our perspective
people who aren't in those high levels
of Hollywood but I don't think that
means that there aren't people there
there's so many examples in the Bible
you have the Daniels who are in high
places all the way to those who weren't
in high places who are doing work like
the apostles and those people and for us
who aren't there I don't think it would
be wise unless you are truly called by
the Holy Spirit to try to go there just
for the purpose of reaching people but
our position to play is definitely
prayer no exactly you know because you
know just like uh you're mentioning sis
it's uh you know a lot of times you know
sometimes you know you can have the
thought well
um I can just go into whatever Circle
you know God will protect me you know
but we have to be careful you know you
know the whole purpose of you know even
you know LED you know light exposing
darkness is to you know really show that
unless we really do have the power of
God you know the darkness will overtake
us no but those are very good points
um so the article that goes on to say I
started hearing experiences of other
depraved who had found their way in this
and it made me feel like I had
permission the actor said of the
Catholic faith
I know that God was using my ego to draw
me to him drawing me away from worldly
desires now that's that's powerful that
he was even able to come to that
conclusion that God was seeking to draw
him away from worldly desires and that's
very true you know because especially
when we think about celebrity
conversions especially and this is
something that
um for those of our views that are
watching to to really pay attention to
because
the Bible says that we shall know them
by their fruits and certainly you know
our purpose in doing this is not to uh
judge anyone in a negative way but if we
say that we're following Christ that
means that there should be a
transformation a supernatural
transformation that is taking place in
the life that reveals that God has done
something special within our hearts and
especially unfortunately you know I've
seen different cases and I know that
we've all seen the examples of and God
bless their hearts you know they're
celebrities you know and say you know
it's they're at the Oscars or whatever
may have you and you know they just you
know start in an R-rated movie where
there was all of this sexually explicit
content and all the cursing and swearing
and violence
and then you know they'll get up on the
Oscar uh Podium and the first thing that
they'll say is that you know I thank God
you know for giving me the ability to do
this and again you know it's not to
uh to you know harmfully judge anyone or
whatever may have you but the Bible
makes it very clear as to what God
condones and what he doesn't condone
and just because we say that that God is
helping us doesn't really mean that he's
helping us uh what it may actually mean
is that there is another God who is
giving them that ability
yeah that's why I asked earlier which
Christianity because let's just assume
that the actors who play in these films
and then go on stage and thank god let's
assume that they're being genuine right
and so looking at Shia LaBeouf's um
statement here it is common for people
to find uh relatability
God can accept me for who I am and I
don't have to prove anything he'll just
say to me which is true which is
beautiful but the issue is when you stay
that way or you think that
um there's no need for change there's no
need for perfection even though God says
be perfect even as I am perfect and I
think that's what people can get into
this idea where yeah I can play these
roles I can live this lifestyle and
still say thank you Lord for saving me
without any real change the one word
that stuck out in that sentence was ego
to me I thought I know God it was using
my ego to draw me to him
I mean if he's drawing him to him to a
Catholic faith I think that's really
interesting because what I guess the
Bible would say this way which God
is drawing him to you I don't know
that's that's my thoughts no it's a very
good point you know and and I'm pretty
sure that you know some of our viewers
are Roman Catholic and uh there may be
some of us who are Roman Catholic who
have maybe uh never heard some of these
things before
and so as we get deeper by God's grace
something should be uh should be made
clear I do want to make one more Point
um I do want to make it clear that
transformation doesn't have a timeline
so just because someone doesn't change
like within a year of conversion you
know that doesn't mean that we should
pass any type of judgment but I think
the reason why a lot of people come into
the faith and then leave is because they
were looking for a change like they were
looking for happiness or what have you
and they didn't find that and that's
because a transformation wasn't
happening so there is there's a
sacrifice that comes with that
transformation that is also coupled with
reward like it's an exchange where God
takes away the bad that is within us and
fills it with
um the the love and the happiness that
we're looking for so if someone comes
into faith and they're not given that
message of transformation it's it makes
sense why they would leave because
they're not finding anything different
from the world right yeah the gospel has
power
that's that's really what what what Paul
alludes to and well he doesn't just
allude to it he flat out pretty much
says it
um what's what's going on at least what
I see going on is you have a lot of what
you're describing and that is a form of
godliness but denying its power and and
the way Paul that's what it says in
second Timothy 3 5 but the way Paul
describes it in Romans the first chapter
he says for I'm not ashamed of the
Gospel of Christ's spirit is the power
of God to Salvation for everyone who
believes without that power of God we
have nothing there there will be no
change in somebody's life and without
change what's the point there's no
difference you're not offering them
anything
and so
um you know we need we need we that's
that's what we need I mean if if you're
not if you're not going to Christ for
power
I don't know why you're going you know
because it's like
it might make you feel better that
you've come to him but at the end of the
day if you don't see Victory and change
you're that's probably going to lead to
depression yeah
I want to throw this out there as you
were talking a thought came to my mind
because the question is what are they
coming for maybe what they get not not
really talking about like the god aspect
is community like they get a family so
to speak and do you think maybe that's
why there's an issue with let's say
let's use the Catholic tradition as an
example because that's what we're
talking about an issue with covering
things up covering sins up abuses on
these things because they're trying to
hold on or keep intact the one thing
that may be
helping them a little bit is that
Community aspect what do you think yeah
and I think people I think people can
come for love you know we've had people
on this show and and they'll tell us
that you know it was love that that Drew
them in
but again in that love you know Christ
you know the Bible says you know in John
3 16 God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son well why did he
give him you know so you can have
eternal life well there are conditions
to that and
you know the simple fact that Jesus was
put or willingly laid his life down on a
cross and should his blood was because
of sin and because we can't overcome sin
and so you know I think there may be
things that you're saying like initially
draw you in and I guess I'm going to the
far down the road saying ultimately
if there's no change there's no point in
coming yeah it's not enough because
you're not you're not going to stick
around
if it doesn't transform you and why
would you you know it makes sense I
think too in Shia's like
um experience I remember seeing an
article with him talking about having
this god-sized hole in his heart
I think he's recognizing like like The
Human Condition of like this is not
fulfilling I need something grander and
there's only this this thing God can
fill this and he sees that and he says
God's drawing me away from from
worldliness but I think the Devils just
steps in during that process and he's
just like oh oh yeah now you want god
well I'll give you something that's kind
of like and and so it gets kind of
confusing if it's going to be sort of
this step in the right direction but no
transformation yeah and it's so hard to
tell in in a lot of these cases because
they make some initial steps and and
like
um like he was talking about
um you want to see fruit
but fruit doesn't happen overnight you
know you plant a seed it grows you know
fruit fruit happens in time and again I
go back to people that we've had on our
show
they've had those seeds planted and the
fruit didn't come for a while but they
were still coming so it's kind of it's
kind of hard in some cases like with
Kanye it was like Izzy or isn't he you
know but it but at some point you think
I'm renouncing
the things that I've said or done that
are contrary to Christianity you want to
see that come out of
that experience why does God allow that
he sees a soul genuinely looking trying
to fill that god-shaped sized whole
and maybe there's a little bud on the
vine and Satan just comes and snatches
it off like why doesn't God step in as
The Bodyguard and say it don't touch
that because that illustration that
Jesus told about casting a seed on soil
fertile you know it's like those seeds
of Truth are cast in many different
settings and situations and uh you know
I think some of these people they they
you know they for whatever reason they
they respond to it immediately but maybe
they don't sink and pick up the Bible
and actually read the Bible because if
you read the Bible there's a lot of
things in there that say you shouldn't
be involved in sexual immorality you
shouldn't be involved in these things so
why would I be in a movie that's
promoting that you know it's like
there's there's kind of a whole line of
logic there that I think you would get
out of that and it's it's a high cost
you follow God it's a high cost yeah
that's good Jeremy Jeremiah 29 13 says
you will seek me and find me when you
seek with me seek with all your with all
your heart yeah so it it's it's got to
be there's Rules of Engagement that the
the Satan and God have established and
those Rules of Engagement
are for the court in heaven and say hey
I can step in because of this and I
can't touch this because of that and we
don't know we see through a glass Darkly
right now but we do know that if we seek
with all our heart we will find the
truth God will lead us to the truth it's
got to be tough because like in that
Parable you were alluding to
you know
seed can easily get choked out and they
haven't left necessarily people that are
in this position they don't necessarily
left all the worldly cares they're still
there
and they still have access to all the
things they have had access to
and if there's you know especially if
there's addictions involved
those those don't break easy
so yeah
goal we've we've taken up a lot of your
time
no no it's um the discussion is a
blessing you know these things are the
dialogue really helps to give more
definite shape you know to what we're
talking about yeah but the article goes
on there's there's a few interesting
points at the end of this article you
know it's really interesting because you
know we all know Rolling Stone is not a
religious outlet but it's very
interesting their take on Shia's
experience in converting to Catholicism
and it's very interesting it says uh the
actor was raised primarily by his artist
mothers the first paragraph and has
spent the last decade of his career
constructing a variety notice of
esoteric and ceremonial performance art
pieces
many of which deal with the extremely
Catholic virtues of humility guilt and
Penance so in principle even before
Shaya took on this role some of the
things that he was already practicing
were very already Catholic if that makes
sense
and so it says but while Catholicism
teaches that Believers can find
Redemption
for their misdeeds by saying a handful
of Hail Marys and attending confession
it's unlikely LaBeouf's reputation and
history of denying the physical abuse he
caused will be solved so that talks
about the whole PR now the last
paragraph
it says news of Le boss conversion comes
days after the actress uh director
Olivia Wilde revealed that the actor's
combative energy ultimately prompted her
to file a buff from the lead world of
her upcoming psychological Thriller
talks about all that
now what we're gonna do we're going to
jump to uh this particular individual
here because this is just to give an
understanding some of of what Shia is is
going through and dealing with now in
some of the uh opening remarks we were
talking about some of the history of
cinematography
and you know I'm not very you know old
in years but I've I have really come to
understand and this is a Biblical
principle
the Bible brings out the grave necessity
of understanding and knowing history is
very interesting you know especially
when you look in the Old Testament part
of the reason why the children of Israel
kept rebelling against God was because
they did not remember nor have a
knowledge of their history retained in
their mind
now as I started to study the history of
cinematography I came across some things
that were very startling now the
particular individual that we have on
the screen is a gentleman by the name of
Tupper Saucy I don't know if anybody's
ever heard of him
uh he wrote a book called rulers of evil
rulers of evil
now this is very interesting this is
taken from the book
this says embedded in the razio sidorium
where the elements of entertainment of
dramatic production composition rhetoric
and eloquence
these courses Interlink with these
spiritual exercises to intensify the
experi experientially ality of Catholic
Doctrine over scripture and
protestantism
they resulted in a genre of spectacular
plays that one distinction as Jesuit
Theater now we're going to read another
statement uh in this book but what that
particular paragraph was talking about
was that during the time of the Middle
Ages the Catholic church was dominating
all of Europe essentially all of the
Catholic states of Europe were dominate
were dominated by the Roman Catholic
system
now in order to counteract the
Protestant Reformation at that time
there there were different means that
were constructed in order to combat that
that was called The Counter Reformation
I don't know if any of our listeners
um even know what uh those those uh
those statements are uh but that's
that's a part of History
now this second paragraph is really
interesting
it says the faculty of Munich College
praised the way Jesuit theater
captivated Protestants especially the
parents of school-aged youngsters now
this is very interesting this is a
direct quotation
there is now this was uh quoted from a
Catholic priest
there is no better means of making
friends out of the Heretics now again
some of our listeners may not know what
a heretic is but uh during the Middle
Ages when the Catholic Church ruled
Europe
if you did not agree with the Catholic
Church on any point whether it was
theology or science or whatever the case
may be if you did not agree with what
they uh taught you were considered a
heretic to give an example there was a
man by the name of Galileo Galilee I'm
pretty sure some of us are familiar with
him he's a he was a genius
and Galileo Galilee
um based upon his studies and all these
things he came to the conclusion that
the world was spherical but the Catholic
church at that time taught that the
world was flat and so as a result of
that Galileo was was deemed a heretic
and he was put on house arrest
and so this goes on to say and the
enemies of the church and filling up the
enrollment of the school then good
high-spirited play acting so this
Catholic priest was saying that the
greatest way to make Heretics stop being
Heretics and to become Catholic is by
giving them theater and play acting
it says uh molier's Jesuit theatricals
in Paris were so popular that even the
dresser were sold out
and so at the very bottom it says even
from the West Indies a Jesuit missionary
reported that nothing has made a
forceful a more forceful impression
on the minds of of the Indians then our
play
now this is very interesting
now I don't know if any of us know who
uh this gentleman was uh this was a
Catholic priest during the uh 17th
century a man by the name of Alphonsus
de liguri
now the reason why we're bringing up uh
this particular individual is that when
you go and watch Shia LaBeouf's
interview with
um uh Bishop Baron Shia he talks about
that one of the things that greatly
helped to lead to his conversion
was the Latin Mass the Latin mass now
again for those of us who are not
familiar with this
uh the Latin Mass that's essentially the
communion service that's done by the
Catholic church and it's done in Latin
it's not done in in another language but
it's particularly done in the Latin
language and Shia was saying that the
Latin Mass was one of the greatest
things that contributed to his
conversion to Roman Catholicism
now this Catholic priest father liguri
he's going to tell us what happens
during the Catholic mass when I read
this this is literally mind-blowing and
again
I know that what we're about to read uh
probably the majority of our listeners
have probably never heard this before
but this is amazing notice
now this is his own words in in his book
we find that in obedience to the words
of his priests Hawk s Corpus so these
are the words that the Catholic priest
says during the mass
God himself descends on the altar so
just to give a background so according
to Catholic theology during the mass
when the priest has that wafer they
literally believe that that wafer turns
into the literal body of Jesus
it says that he comes wherever they call
him and as often as they call him and
places himself in their hands even
though they should be his enemies
and after having come he remains
entirely at their disposal
they move him as they please from one
place to another they may if they wish
shut him up in the Tabernacle or expose
him on the altar
so liguri he's essentially talking about
that the priest is so powerful that he
can literally move God
as embodied in this wafer wherever he
pleases
and at the bottom it says
they may if they choose eat his flesh or
give him as food of others
oh how very great is their power
now this is the second paragraph This is
this is amazing it says oh how wonderful
Dignity of the priest oh wonderful Cries
Out Saint Augustine
in their hands as in the womb of the
Blessed version that's speaking about
Mary
the Son of God becomes incarnate
hence priests notice hence priests are
called the parents of Jesus Christ
now for those of us who are acquainted
with our Bibles we know that the Bible
does not teach this and again this is by
no means seeking to attack our Catholic
brothers and sisters who may be watching
this or those who have never heard this
before
but this is what the Catholic Church
believes and teaches
it says hence priests uh are called the
parents of Jesus Christ such is the
title that Saint Bernard gives them now
notice this statement
thus the priests May in a certain manner
be called the creator of his creator
now from a Biblical standpoint that is
pure blasphemy
pure blasphemy and Shia he he said that
this Latin Mass where all of these
Blasphemous things take place according
to the Bible is what led to his
conversion to Roman Catholicism but the
amazing thing about it is is that
there's a reason for this
now I'm going to quote from a book
called The Great controversy now for
those of our listeners who are not
familiar the great controversy is one of
the the best uh expositions uh that's
been done on the books of Daniel and the
Revelation a Timeless uh Timeless volume
it says the religious service of the
Romans church is a most impressive
ceremonial
it's gorgeous display and solemn rights
Fascinate the senses of the people so
this is to give some sympathy to what
Shai was going through because as he was
seeing the Latin Mass his senses were
being overwhelmed by what he was
experiencing
it says the silent and silence the voice
of reason and conscience the eye is
Charmed magnificent churches imposing
processions golden altars jeweled Shrine
choice choice paintings and exquisite
sculpture appeal to the love of beauty
now I personally had the privilege to
visit a St Patrick's Cathedral in New
York
a number of years ago and anyone who's
ever been to a Roman Catholic Church
will tell you that from a pure aesthetic
standpoint it is very beautiful
I mean the the the architecture is is
truly breathtaking honestly
but as we're going to go on to read that
as a result of it being so overwhelming
to the senses that unfortunately Satan
uses this in order to Blind the mind
it says the ear is also captivated the
music is unsurpassed the rich notes of
the d-tone organ blending with the
melody of many voices as it swells
through the lofty domes and pillared
aisles of her grand Cathedrals cannot
fail to impress the mind with awe and
reverence
so as Shai was experiencing these things
the awe and reverence of what was taking
place around him was so overwhelming him
that in his mind he believed that this
must be the movings of God in his life
now isn't that interesting that it's
like you know the devil's really smart
he knows when to make something like
make fun of it or whatever like that but
in a worship situation if he really
wants you to believe something he's like
setting all the right things in position
so that like all your senses are like
yes this is it you know
but it's like yes this is it for
something that like I I was kind of
Blown Away by that statement like the
Creator can become yeah yeah is the
Creator's Creator yeah
uh yeah it's all about feeling Satan's
Satan's idea is uh to convert the heart
is away from God is to use feelings and
and your senses and to make you feel as
if something has happened inside you
you're overwhelmed so therefore it must
be true what are we seeing here that
coming to Christ should not be an
emotional experience not at all I think
God made emotions we we have emotions
for a reason like like we know that God
feels emotions he's upset at the people
and he's like all right Moses I'm gonna
wipe him out and I'm gonna start over
with you
that's a that's an emotional experience
that is an interesting window into God
you know
um God experiences anger God experiences
love laughter Joy you know like all
these emotions that he gave to us so I
think like in our involvement with you
know getting involved in in a
relationship with God
I mean when you first fall in love was
that not an emotional experience yeah so
you have this emotional experience with
God but I think God's saying you know
come let us reason together like like I
want to show you the reasons why this is
the way that it is your emotions can
lead you astray that's what's leading
your thinking is it your brain or
something else right what you've learned
or what you have felt yeah right cart
before the horse kind of a thing you
know it's like God created and designed
the system like that so you can't say
it's wrong but it's when it drives us
yeah it can easily uh manipulate us and
I think that's what exactly happened to
Eve she walked up the Bible gives you
that little piece of information the
fruit looked good to her to eat like
like the emotion of like oh that looks
yummy it's crazy because this this whole
experience that the the Catholic church
has set up you know all this beauty that
they've put and all the Aesthetics and
everything the size the sound
Israel had something similar yeah I
agree but it didn't there were checks
and balances in the way that
really prevented their
emotions from leading their thinking
yeah you know and that's I think that's
where
you know in the in and yes there were
priests you know and the sanctuary
service and you know the players had to
come and and experience the sights and
the sounds and the smells and the whole
bit
but it was done it was done in a way
that God
set up you know and and in that there's
there's wisdom and there's safeguards
and
if elements are over emphasized that's
where it gets you know imbalanced and
God knew in the sanctuary service for
example the Right Mix you know it's one
thing you don't see them doing in a
Catholic service is
that person having to go forward and
slit a lamb's throat and collect the
blood you know that that had to be
intense I'm sure there was a lot going
in the mind and having to think through
that process yes there were emotions
with that but you're you're having to
Grapple with like wow I had to take a
life I had to take the best this cost me
and then you know the priest is there to
also teach and guide and and direct
their mind to yeah and what do you think
that costs God you know
and so there's elements there
but it's just I think it's imbalanced
it's not the right mix there's one more
thing I want to pick your brain about in
terms of the element because it was not
just Beauty it was also the music I
don't know about any of you but I've
never seen a drum set in a Catholic
Church you know so so it wasn't I'm sure
there wasn't a heavy base it was
probably more of solemn music yet the
effect was still
according to this or according to the
Bible negative so to speak so where
where do what do we do with that
music is designed to open the heart to
receive a message
and so that's why we play a piece of
music for a altar call or something you
know it's like it's it's really it's it
is really designed to make this decision
that you're making this this prompting
that you're feeling from the Holy Spirit
you're stepping up an experience and
music helps kind of heighten that
experience right yeah it doesn't mean
that it doesn't again it kind of goes
back to it doesn't mean that the
elements that they have are all
necessarily wrong
it's just the way that they're being
used yeah you know yeah it's like we
talk about this all the time you know
it's like people will approach us and
they'll be like is it wrong to do this
and it's like well
it kind of depends you know like what is
your motivation what are you doing yeah
you know and that's where it's like God
knows God knows what's in the heart and
just like he knows what's in the heart
of so many Catholics right God knows
what's there but you know to the music
part it's like yeah it's designed in a
way to create a response just like he's
saying but it doesn't mean
that the music's bad but I think like
like to kind of dive deep into your
thing without taking up too much of your
time here Samuel
um the the the
um the the choir music and everything
and it just is so Angelic so I can
imagine that your senses are are being
opened your heart's being open whereas I
think a lot of the the just heavy
rhythmatic drum stuff it it does the
opposite effect
if you could say that or it opens your
heart in a different way exactly I think
I think the kind of one different in
their in their experience maybe it just
unlocks different emotions yeah yeah
that's true yeah you know that's a very
interesting point uh you know to bring
up in regards to music because we're
actually going to touch on that just
very briefly uh before this is over uh
because it's really interesting how that
even ties into all of this this uh
closing statement it says the religion
of a religion of externals is attractive
to the unrenewed heart now for those of
our listeners who who don't know what
that means the unrenewed heart that's
just simply talking about a person who's
not converted uh and you can even be
unconverted and be going to church you
know just a very good example you know
the Apostle Peter before he was
converted you know he unfortunately did
a lot of things you know and it
eventually led him to deny Christ and he
not only denied Christ but he denied
Christ by cursing and swearing
and so unfortunately Peter's heart was
unrenewed
and so it goes on to say the Pomp and
ceremony of the Catholic Worship have a
seductive bewitching Power by which many
are deceived and they come to look upon
the Roman Church as the very Gate of
Heaven
now moving along very quickly we talked
about Kanye West and some of uh some of
our other statements now Kanye West's
experiences very interesting very
interesting as we talk about Shia
LaBeouf and Roman Catholicism
uh because I remember when this was
gaining a lot of prominence like back in
2019 you know the Lord you know just put
it on my mind to go and do some digging
in regards to this and what I found was
very interesting
this is a Kanye West Sunday service a
religious experience or celebrity call
we're not going to go through the
details uh but it essentially talks
about that uh in this worship experience
and even in this next article right here
it says that Connie was Sunday service
he is the church where even NPR
highlights the fact that Kanye West is
really the focus of these worship
services that it's not even really God
but it's really Connie that's at the
center of the worship
now going on this says Kanye West Sunday
service isn't exactly church but it is
Christian very interesting
now this is talking about his former
wife uh Kim Kardashian
now
this says Kim on the other hand said in
a 2018 interview with Vogue that the
whole family identifies as religious now
this is interesting
because again this is not to land blast
Kim Kardashian and her family but
it's very evident that that family sadly
is not walking with the Lord
um and you know those sisters you know
either all of them or very many of them
uh are very promiscuous sexually and and
they Advocate things that are not
biblically sound
and so as a result of that we know that
the religion that at least they're
practicing is not biblical
it goes on to say we are very Christian
and our work ethic and our discipline
comes from so many years at Catholic
School
so their moral framework was fashioned
by them going to Catholic School
interesting point
now this is from another article this is
actually from a Catholic uh news agency
and this says Kanye West Jordan Peterson
who some of our listeners may be
familiar with and the Allure of
Catholicism and I would really encourage
our hearers to go in and and and uh read
this article but it's amazing
this article again without going into
the details it talks about that those
who adhere to Kanye West Sunday service
those who adhere to the teachings of
Jordan Peterson if they follow on in
that path that they will eventually
become Roman Catholic
now I'm just going to end with this
particular slide here because you know
even as we mentioned before I don't in
any way nor I know that none of us are
are trying to do this at all to try to
denigrate the sincerity that that uh
Shaya is expressing and at the end of
the day you know we don't know his heart
and you know we pray that by God's grace
that the Lord continue to may continue
to grow him in a genuine experience and
really bring him to a knowledge of the
truth uh but this picture here on the
screen is just a symbol of bondage just
a symbol of bondage
uh and I'm just going to quickly read a
passage from The Book of Romans
uh just to get a better understanding
this is Romans
chapter 6 and verse 16. notice where the
Bible says it says know ye not that to
whom ye yield yourselves servants to
obey his servancy are to whom ye obey
whether of sin unto death or of
obedience
unto righteousness and unfortunately
when we yield ourselves to the lust of
the flesh that Galatians 5 talks about
we become Servants of sin and Servants
of Satan but God wants to free us from
this bondage you know the Bible says all
throughout the Book of John you know
whom the sun sets free you know he is
free indeed and bringing out that
principle of The Liberation that takes
place when we receive Christ into our
hearts
uh but I'm going to read a statement
from a very powerful book called The
Desire of Ages uh this is uh this book
is actually in the Library of Congress
as one of the greatest books written uh
on the Life of Christ
now this really helps to encapsulate the
work of conversion and this is all of
our prayer for uh for Shaya and anyone
who really has a desire to come to the
Lord
it says when the soul surrenders itself
to Christ a new power takes possession
of the new heart
A change is wrong in which man can never
accomplish for himself it is a
supernatural work bringing a
supernatural element into Human Nature
in the middle it says a soul thus kept
in possession by the heavily agencies is
impregnable to the assaults of Satan but
unless we do yield ourselves to uh to
the control of Christ we shall be
dominated by the wicked one at the
bottom
it says
if we do not cooperate with the heavily
agencies Satan will take possession of
the heart and will make it his Abiding
Place
it says the only defense against evil is
the indwelling of Christ in the heart
through faith in his righteousness
unless we become vitally connected with
God and not just you know just a passive
acquaintance not just flipping up you
know and opening up our Bibles every now
and then but a consistent loving intense
relationship with our Lord it says we
can never resist the unhollowed effects
of self-love self-indulgence and
temptation to sin and again at the
bottom
it says without a personal acquaintance
with Christ and a continual communion we
are at the mercy of the enemy
and shall do his bidding in the end and
this is by no means to leave a gloom and
doom picture but the reality is is that
the Bible depicts that we're in a
spiritual warfare
and Satan the enemy of souls is is
laboring earnestly
for our destruction and if we are going
to be free from that satanic influence
we really have to run to Jesus and I
really want to emphasize this
for the listeners because especially
consuming content content like little
light Studios and other Ministries that
are really seeking to shed light on
things God is giving these privileges to
us not for us to just watch and to say
wow that's amazing you know look at all
of the satanic things that are happening
in the background when we watch these
videos and and all of these different
programs these are efforts that God is
making to speak directly to our hearts
and it would be certainly a shame to
watch all of these amazing programs and
to still go back and watch the same
thing so that's just my encouragement
for us that as we watch these different
things and as we share them that we will
pray that the Lord will really help us
to turn away from sin and to really
follow Jesus amen well said amen well
thank you so much Samuel for coming and
breaking this down for us you know uh it
really information is just information
no matter who gets it if it doesn't
Transform You It's Not Gonna Save you
that's right and I think that's the
that's the bullet point that you have
brought out and very clearly in this uh
this message so you know thank you and
all of you guys that are listening out
there
um if you want to check out Samuel's
Channel Samuel say it again yes so we
are on uh YouTube and our name is glad
Tidings 3 A.M Glad Tidings 3 A.M and
when you go and look at it our logo is
like a like a Earth symbol with a Three
Angels around it it's awesome it's
awesome so check out Samuel's Channel
and if you want to hear him he's got
some great content on there but thank
you for coming by and blessing us and we
hope those of you guys out there that
are listening you got a blessing out of
today's uh topic and you know pray for
these people these people are are also
you know if he's feeling the pull of
coming out of the world and and changing
that means that God is is tugging on his
heart and the devil's probably not going
to let him go very easy so we need to
pray for these people that God will
penetrate the darkness surround him with
people who can share truth with him and
that his heart will receive that truth
so that the roots can take uh hold and
really grow and fruit into something
beautiful so amen thank you guys for
listening thank you all you you
supporters out there and don't forget
check out our t-shirts we believe in
wearing your witness so lightwear dot
shop and we got a lot of cool designs
thumb through that and we'll see you
guys on the next weekend
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the video Bible study Series
where we will explore a variety of Bible
topics using video and print what is
humility do we need God's law can I
understand the Holy Spirit yes you can
and we're going to solve that today in
five minutes or less they're designed to
engage You by watching a five minute
video having a discussion on the topic
and Diving deeper into it with a lesson
study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has activities
overall we developed this project for
you to have a closer walk with Jesus as
you explore relevant topics either in a
group setting or on your own we hope you
find these a blessing if you want more
information go to
www.littlelightstudios.tv or find us on
your favorite social media platform
hi you might not know me because I work
mostly behind the scenes
but my name is Michael and I'm the
director of little live Studio's 3D
Department
right now we're experimenting with new
technology where we're trying to blend
reality with the virtual world it's more
efficient and offer us the opportunity
to make higher quality Productions with
better visuals by using the online
engine software it gives us the
possibility to create realistic virtual
environments for sets in a short amount
of time
we are working with what we have because
we do have Financial limits that's why
we're working toward getting an LED wall
in the future because it will allow us
to use extended reality this simply
means that we don't need green screen
anymore it will save us tremendous time
in the post compositing process
we will also have realistic accurate
lighting that comes from Led wall which
matches the subject and the set in real
time
actors are able to see the set rather
than having to imagine the scenes within
the confines of the green screen
so that's what we've been up to here at
Levi Studios
we're so thankful for the ways that God
has blessed us
and we're so excited for what he has for
us in the future
[Music]